find that both conceptually and in terms
of style that there are lots of interest
in parallels between jazz improvisation
and how theoretical physicists which is
what I do for a living how we actually
come up with new ideas come up with new
physics the one connection is the
mysterious way that quantum particles
actually move their quantum particle
actually according to the rules of
quantum mechanics as it moves from point
A to point B will actually traverse all
possible paths when you think about this
particle as an improvisation as a way a
jazz soloist might actually improvise
from a starting note to finish a note
the jazz musician a very skilled one
will consider many possible notes that
could be compatible with the melodic
line similar to how a quantum particle
will consider all these possible paths
from from point A to point B there are
times when I'm playing and I'm
improvising that I might actually as a
device as an improvisational device I
might think about a physics idea because
what that will do is it will get me it
will get me from thinking to
intellectually about what notes I'm
playing because the name of the game as
Charlie Parker said it's a practice but
when is when you're up there playing
throw it all away